seek guidance so one of things i'm a big
fan of is if I don't know what I'm
getting into I don't have the answers
I've never done it before I try to sync
guidance that comes one through modern
success is the name of this channel it's
why I tried to do the top tens and
espressos to learn people who've done it
before it's what saved my first business
is a 19 year old entrepreneur find
someone who's already done it and try to
model their success the other way to do
it is through actual mentors through
people who actually done it who you
could have a conversation with not just
watch video on or read a book about or
you know watch an interview on and so
how this relates to my book is I've
never done a book before writes my first
book i've done a lot of other products
and marketing and you know building a
brain but book is totally new for me and
so I don't want to assume that I have
all the answers on how to create a
best-selling book I'm super confident in
the product I love the book itself I
love the content I read it and I get
alive I think it will change lives as
well but the marketing the exposure how
to promote it I have some ideas but I
don't pretend to be an expert in doing
it and so one of the people don't have
reached out to for help is Ryan Holliday
who is the master book marketer we've
had him on this channel for his top 10
rules for success video with the bonus
11th rule and when I first talked about
the book he's like can you save me the
manuscript let me look it over let me
see what I think about it and of course
I only want Ryan's help if he actually
likes the book I hate having somebody
who's on my team just doing it for the
work they gotta they gotta like the
product right they got to feel
emotionally connected to what we're
selling what we're marketing otherwise
for me it doesn't work and i wasn't able
to send him the script because my
publisher said it's not ready yet we
gotta send them a clean copy we don't
want to have a bad first impression and
I said you know what with Ryan it's okay
you know we have a decent relationship
i'm sure it'll be okay we have to go
back with the second version he's not
going to be too harsh on spelling
mistakes or any changes we said no no no
we can't send it out this is frustrating
it's like a cake when can I send it out
and then finally this week I got the
okay to sent me a clean job they said
okay you want to send it out to Ryan
anybody else here it is you can send it
and I was so excited and look through it
so excited so excited
and I send it to Ryan and he wrote back
I was just last night and he said I'm
gonna check it out on the plane he's
just going through his book launch right
now and he's going to give me some
feedback and see what my people to do
together so it's a it's a you know big
moment to have that final draft kind of
ready to go and hopefully get some good
feedback from Ryan but more importantly
the bigger message is a seek guidance if
you haven't done what you're trying to
do then don't just try to come up with
every solution yourself that's the
that's the slowest way the success the
faster way is to model and to seek
guidance with people who've done it
before get their advice build that team
so you can get there a lot faster let's
get to the questions first up is Jiwon
many things that take away from every
video can't wait to read your book I
appreciate the loved you on I can't wait
for you to read the book I'm so excited
it's been a year ish of writing and we
still have until the Sun before comes
out it's crazy how long it takes but I
am super excited to have you guys read
it to hopefully have your lives change
by going through the the theory and the
exercises in there just so excited and
appreciate the support and this journey
has been fun to kind of share have you
guys tag along next up is Simeon my
question is the following how do you
separate your time during the week when
you get up when you start the actual
work do you work on your own or you're
always formed by your team when you
finish work and perhaps go home in the
moment you feel that you are delighted
with what you've done what do you do
before bed you read a book what are your
hobbies I'm not really at the business
on and on and on alright so that's a
great question I'm a big believer in
Chungking my time I'm a big believer in
setting routines and habits and
structure so my wife and I try to go to
bed we start getting for bed around
eleven that's not always possible
because we both do salsa dancing and
that keeps us up later sometimes so we
can't always do that but when we're home
we try to start getting ready for bed at
eleven we'll do a meditation that we're
playing with called headspace and then
we go to sleep we usually wake up 7
30ish somewhere around there she has to
wake up and get ready for work I wake up
and start going through my regular kind
of morning routine I'll watch some
videos i will add some comments i will
do a morning workout i will then start
my official work at ten usually so from
when i wake up to 10
it's it's workout it's you know making
my wife's and breakfast if I wake up
with her it's cleaning up like for me
also being part of a clean environment
like if my desk is super messy I can't
really work so just cleaning up from the
day before so you should start at ten
from ten is pretty consistent where I'll
be I spend time answering comments
checking out a certain number of
websites there's about 20 websites that
I check out every day do my YouTube
comments and then answering the email
from my priority folder which is my team
media big customers important partners
and I'll make sure that gets done every
morning apart from that every day become
something different so monday is my tds
day charms and salsa so Alex comes over
and we spend the whole day together so
he'll come over at 10 and we'll spend
the rest of the day working on tds stuff
on Tuesday is my book writing day so I
usually end up going to a whole foods or
starbucks and working on before was
writing the book now it's been writing
edits for the book and it's going to
evolve to become marketing the book and
creating content around the book so I
block off tuesday for that wednesday is
my video recording days so today is
Wednesday when I'm filming this I film
all my videos on Wednesday and they get
released over the course of the week
Thursday is my public facing day it's my
media day it's my hangouts day it's my
interviews day it's my coffee meetings
phone call day so it's usually back to
back to back stuff and then Friday is my
get other stuff done day my bigger
projects day J reyez often comes over
and we'll work on projects it might be
launching a new website or landing pages
or I meet with two key guys on my team
every week on Friday via google hangouts
so some of the bigger picture stuff to
help grow the business that's my data
work on the business building stuff and
then that repeats and as my life changes
like I wasn't a party tds as an owner I
was just an investor before I didn't I
didn't run the company Monday's used to
be something else and as I find new
things that I want to try or get
involved with or I find myself being
pulled away into something else then I
switch up my schedule to be able to
accommodate that the one caveat that
everything is when I'm in the flow on
something I will break all the rules and
just try to stay in that moment of
Oh for as long as possible because the
stuff that you make is gold like the
stuff that you will create when you are
in flow is so much more important than
your daily tasks that you have to get
done in terms of hobbies or home sending
my other time will do a workout three
times a week with a personal trainer
here at TDS sean has been on the channel
before I'll do salsa dancing multiple
times for a week I'll teach a salsa
class on sunday nights but also come to
the socials and the dancing and the
parties it's I still love dances how I
met my wife and what else saturday is my
data plan the day for Nina so will
usually have it's my job to playing what
we're going to do so as you plan the
whole day which usually involves
visiting at least two different food
places and she's a big food person it's
summer now so i'll hop on the best bud
head downtown and pop up on a few places
i think that's it you guys have other
questions let me know next up is peter
how do you find mentors as a young guy
who wants to start a business i'm 20
years old so i had my first business
when i was 19 years old I felt like I
needed to have mentors in my company I
didn't know anybody my parents my
ferrets that's family plus parents
equals ference so my ference weren't
entrepreneurs I didn't know
entrepreneurs it just wasn't part of my
upbringing and so I went to the bank I
thought hey a bank they're supposed to
help entrepreneurs right they would help
me and they said do you need a loan that
no I don't need a loan i'm just i'm
trying to get connections i'm trying to
find the mentor and that's how little I
knew about the industry and how to find
mentors but I the first real mentor that
I found wasn't wasn't a person I ever
met it was it was Bill Gates I was in a
software company and I was trying to go
breathing myself and sucking and failing
and then realize I'm not the first gotta
try to sell soccer before who's done it
and had lots of success Bill Gates
obviously did running Microsoft and so
look at how he got started and most of
my early mentors were aspirational
mentors people who I've never met but
they still got guidance from them that
being said to step back a little bit my
parents were insanely great mentors for
me just to teach me how to be a human
being values how to treat people being
true to your word hard work all that
stuff came from my parents but the
entrepreneurial stuff business stuff I
had to go elsewhere for and
to this day I started the channel I do
the top 10 Indian spreads and all this
most of the series to learn from famous
entrepreneurs is for you guys but is for
me because I want to learn from those
guys too and I consider everybody that
we feature on the channel to be one of
my mentors and I learned something from
all of them and the goal is never to be
them but the take something from them to
be the best version of myself next up is
choreographic arts I'm working I think
I'm doing my best not sure yet if
everything what I'm doing now is going
to take me where I want to go but I'm
doing it because is going to be worse to
regret and not try the problem is how do
I know how do I know if all what I'm
trying is taking me somewhere some good
things are happening but I feel my
progress is kind of slow sometimes so it
never happens as fast as you want to
happen piri you know like as
entrepreneurs we always want things that
happen today and it and it takes time
for it to happen it tastes continuous
grind hustle effort to make things
happen I think for for all big matters
for business for career for
relationships the most important thing
is to listen to your heart as long as
you feel like you are still loving this
like it's still the right thing to do
like it still makes you come alive the
person you're with this still feels like
it's the right person be with the work
that you're doing still feels like it's
you're contributing your learning you're
gaining from it the business that you've
started your still contributing the
customers and adding value because a lot
of the logical things that might come
into play like I'm not making enough
money I'm not hitting the goal I'm not
whatever yet are negated by the fact
that you love this thing that you're
working on and if you continue to love
it then you'll get to where you want to
go all the logical things will work out
but it doesn't make sense right now you
can't rationalize it right now because
it's just an emotional feeling but
that's the most important one because if
you do love it then you'll put in the
time you put in the work you put in the
hustle you keep going you'll drive
through all the steps that everybody
thinks are too crazy to do to get to
where you need to go and it doesn't the
path is unclear for most people like you
don't know where the final destination
is going to be I didn't know I was going
to be doing YouTube videos you go back
to when I stood at my company I wanted
to inspire entrepreneurs that bigger
vision hasn't changed I want to help
entrepreneurs I want to believe in
entrepreneurs I want them to believe in
themselves that's been from the
beginning but
how I executed has changed many many
many times and I followed what I've been
personally interested in excited by if
somebody just said go do YouTube because
it's a good marketing strategy and I
tried it and I hated it it doesn't
matter how much logical sense it is to
do I wouldn't have success because I
hate doing it meanwhile i started it
because i love doing it at the beginning
I wasn't making any money like it wasn't
helping my business at all I wasn't
getting comments I wasn't getting
advertising revenue I wasn't getting
brand deals I wasn't very good either
but I kept doing it because I love doing
it cuz I look forward to coming in and
shooting myself because I felt like I
was growing I was getting better
personally and so you don't know how
it's all going to make sense but the
most important thing is that you're
doing work that you love if you do work
that you love it will make sense
eventually you'll be able to make sense
of it looking backwards but looking
ahead you have no idea how it's all
going to align for you so for me that's
the most important thing do you still
love the work that you're doing and if
you do then find ways to continue doing
it if you don't can you adjust can you
tweak can you shift to make your work
more enjoyable or do you do drop it and
go do something else and many times
that's the answer to like forget that
like you you went in for the wrong
reason or you went in for the right
reason but you don't love it anymore so
now it is the wrong reason to keep going
switch and go do something that you love
xandos writing in I'm still thinking
about whether i'm going to buy your book
or audio book i still have plenty of
time though yep the book is coming out
december six I don't know when the audio
book comes out I don't know if we have a
date for that if it's the same date or
not they know the choice is obvious you
buy both bro you buy both audiobook and
the regular book and you can gift the
other one to your friends run their
writing in PS hope you had a happy
Father's Day Father's Day was great
Father's Day actually on the Monday I
got to go to hate in school and they had
a father-son kind of play afternoon
monday is usually my tds day so I
borrowed Alex car and I drove up to
Hayden school and spent the spent an
hour with him playing frisbee and doing
stickers and tattoos and bunch of fun
stuff and then and then came back so
father's day was was pretty amazing
that's part of being an entrepreneur
hopefully is allowing yourself to create
that time to go and spend time with the
most people most important people in
your life too next up CJ
p I see you're wearing your static chaos
shirt he sent you you must really like
that shirt yeah when people send me
stuff I try to incorporate it in I can't
do it for everybody doesn't always make
sense for what I'm doing but clothing is
relatively easy to incorporate so if you
send me something in the next edition of
mail time I might open it up and I might
work you never know next up is na young
I don't like audio in general but maybe
because the readers weren't as good as
Evan will be listen I'm gonna do the
audiobook it's going to be fire it'll be
fire I'm already excited to do it I'm
going to insist on it being me it's
gonna be amazing i'm super excited by it
it's going to be a hard decision if you
are not an audio person I want to be the
person that brings you over the audio
just to listen to the book I think it's
going to be pretty good but I agree with
you and that most audio books that you
listen to if it's not the author
themselves its weak I don't know why
office wouldn't do it it bothers me that
they don't do it I think it's just
better when the office is it themselves
you got to put in the hustle and do it
yourself next up dr phoenix hey thanks
for the shoutout and I meant every word
Evan already sub to your newsletter and
we'll be keeping a close look out for
when the book drops can't wait to read
it yeah if you guys are on a newsletter
we put it at the end of every video
typically it's the easiest way to get
updates on what's going on where they
have a special google hangouts going on
or the book is coming out you guys will
hear about the book on youtube channel 2
i'll have at least a couple videos
talking about it promoting it but if you
want to hear about if i'm coming to your
city especially i usually only put that
in the newsletter sometimes on the
youtube channel but then also any
special events and hang out some people
feel like they missed the hangouts or
why wasn't I notified about the hangouts
I do it through my newsletter list so if
you're on there then you'll get notified
so you can check it out link will be at
the end of video and also in the
description last up is Eric Evan just a
beautiful raw and honest video believe
nation is awesome and you rock much love
Eric you guys rock believe nation rocks
if I make this these videos it makes me
come alive I love sharing with you guys
I love that as an impact on what you're
doing and your day to day life and I
hope that you guys use the content to
then inject something meaningful into
the work you're doing and do do the work
to try to be the best version of
yourself because so many people are
playing here where they should be here
if you really think about any for
yourself but also the people around you
are you actually being the best version
of yourself are you doing everything
that you can't do to move forward on
your
goals and for most people is no no you
are not living up to your potential
period and so hopefully by having
resources like these videos around you
it lets you get a little bit closer
because I think if you have the skills
and you have insane potential then it's
your responsibility to chase it it's
your responsibility to to try to reach
your potential for yourself but also for
the people around you because you can
have an impact on the community that
you're not having because you're
slacking off or you don't believe in
yourself enough or you come up with
excuses where you should be playing at
this level and that's my goal is for you
guys to get up here play at that level
live the life that you should be living
have the impact that you should be
having and have the happiness that you
deserve as well so thank you guys so
much for watching I love to know what
you think about the topic about getting
feedback in seeking guidance from others
if you have a question about my book or
the book writing process leave it down
in the comments below and I'll me
feature you in the next edition of this
series thank you guys for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon